things are getting more and more serious
between kourtney kardashian and travis
barker and now a source is telling et
that scott disick who shares three
children with the keeping up with the
kardashians star has quote unsettled ill
will towards his ex and her new rock
star boyfriend i'm not putting my energy
there the source explains quote courtney
and scott are definitely not as close as
they once were scott has some unsettled
ill will towards courtney and travis
being together and courtney is over the
jealousy she thinks scott needs to grow
up i've seen it all of course this all
comes after scott made his feelings
known in an alleged dm he sent to
courtney's other ex eunice benjamin in
august at the time the 28 year old model
who dated court on and off for years
prior to her current relationship with
travis posted a screenshot of some dms
he claimed were from scott the alleged
post included a pda
pic of court and travis on their italian
vacation along with a message allegedly
sent by scott reading quote yo is this
chick okay bro like what is this in the
middle of italy yeah
the push founder and the blink 182
drummer have been inseparable since
confirming their relationship earlier
this year courtney even helped travis
conquer his fear of flying after his
2008 near-death crash and the source
tells et that traveling with courtney on
his first flight since the accident
brought them even closer i'm just like
living life and
whatever happens happens
quote they have gotten so much more
serious to the point that they could
very well spend the rest of their lives
together they are both very committed
and very happy their kids are also
excited about a bigger closer future
together the source adds that courtney
has helped travis regain confidence in
many aspects of his life and he quote
can't imagine his life without her at
this point i mean it was beautiful
amazing
quote travis makes courtney laugh and he
is honest sincere genuinely caring and a
great dad lover and partner the list
goes on and on courtney loves all of
those qualities about him and finds him
very endearing
i love it as for scott a separate source
previously told et that the lovebirds
don't care about his opinion but court's
upset it's now public her frustration
here according to the source is that she
always tries to protect the little ones
from what's said about the family
publicly
quote scott and courtney have always had
a public united front and have done a
great job co-parenting courtney doesn't
want her kids seeing anything online
that makes it look like their parents
don't get along
[Music]
you